you should be [ __ ] dead all right
when nothing happened nothing bad
happened totally fine I was like okay oh
okay you gotta understand that like when
I climbed in here I didn't want to tell
Bob that I didn't have a lot of room
don't admit defeat but let me just say
if I sneezed while I was laying in bed I
would have broken my nose like I would
go forward a couple inches and I smack
into the ceiling like I remember laying
in the bed and I could hear everything
in the like dorm above me and it was
like I heard people jumping around like
partying I heard people having sex and
I'm just like
worth it we have so much room for
activity but then I remember like a few
days after we did this one morning my
alarm goes off or whatever it's like
early and I'm like okay I gotta get out
of bed and I had forgotten that I was in
a bunk and so I like in a daze it's dark
I like climb out of bed and just
suddenly I'm falling
[Laughter]
what did you think like I know you were
asleep you woke it up but I was like I
fall and I don't remember what happened
and then I was on the ground
I mean so I was really sleep I'm not a
morning person I wake up super slowly so
I was laying in bed mostly asleep and it
was like if you imagine what it would
look like in a cartoon yeah if you're
you're in an office building in a window
office and somebody has leaped out of a
window above yours and they come flying
by your window like they're parachuting
or something like I'm just laying in bed
and I just see Mark's just like whoa
and then Marx is on the floor and I
don't even know if I rolled over I think
he bubbled like yeah okay and I'm like
yeah okay after I go
you okay but you you really like rolled
out like you were just gonna put your
foot on the floor so the way you fell
was just like tumbling like whoa whoa
God but that was the only time I made
that mistake so um it was good
[Music]